bon aujourd'hui je voulais faire une
chance rires mais je sais pas trop de
quoi parler je me suis rappelé que
j'étais une petite merde qu'est un peu
trop pris la confiance du coup je me
faire le détendre un peu mais pour une
fois on va arrêter de se cacher derrière
une voix grave et on va semer notre voie
peu viril d'adolescentes 15 ans on y va
c'est pas short est déjà tombé sur mes
vidéos un mec pas très drôle comme ils
disent une star des ados j'arrête pas
dire que j'ai grandi car j'ai attendu
salon tanger qui fuit quand j'ai ma
barbe plus de leçons de mes 18 ans je
suis plus et moite sur youtube que tu
speed gens sur twitter depuis l'enfance
on le répète quand est ce que tu vas
chez coiffeur je me suis fait tout seul
c'est tout seul déçu prière mon corps on
dirait une feuille la messe que je
connais pas bien 9 millions d'abonnés
seulement de ça mais sur facebook dans
la vraie vie je suis plus nulle
thermique de l'émission change de look
la première medica marché mais je n'ai
rien inventé je suis la parfaite fusion
nul que les feuilles qui devrait
toujours bien qu'hors de l'âge pour
faire ce choix que j'assume mais je vais
tout faire refaire maintenant que j'ai
d'études explique le garçon écrit
s'agace est loin d'être satisfaisante
j'suis méprisant je suis mes 10 ans chez
qui fait que son fils de 10 ans
verizon christophe grisaille de
l'autodérision fils tous les styles de
l'autodérision et si tu sais parler de
toi mais ils sont
[Musique]
encore prêts ue tout inquiète faut pas
être heureux jno pôle emploi quand mes
patrons pluvieux à ce que tu as un
enfant gâté cas toujours eu ce qu'ils
voulaient à un vieux con raté qui
regrettent ces jours passés tout pour
faire des vues animaux et famille loin
des sujets importants réchauffement et
famille j'en veux plus d'amour à des
gens que je tenais pas qu'à mes proches
trop dépôt pour remettre en question
j'accepte d'aller reprendre comme ça
tous les jours
dates les plus grands talents youtube
copie les autres c'est pas masquer faire
le buzz tout l'espace et rue je fais la
morale à d'autres comme si j'étais au
dessus
mais comme beaucoup de potes j'ai changé
c'est sûr je les ai déçu dans l'écran
ont même sur mech foule euros et
bienveillant dans la vie je m'aime je
suis fait un média local un rongeur mal
les réactions des gens j'ai que la vente
n pourtant mes vidéos qui marche le
mieux sont celles où chine les miennes
[Musique]